what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 6 of the halide 2018 slash
highlight 3 tutorial series in the
previous video we got our BOTS basically
to the point where they run around they
collect enough halite to get basically
somewhere equal or less or two three
three three halite and then they attempt
to go drop it off and we're seeing that
they're getting stuck at the depot here
the at least the one of the more likely
reasons why they're getting stuck is
first of all they're just always going
to get stuck so if we look back at our
code when we go to deposit the ship is
going to continue trying to move to the
shipyard position but at some point the
ship will get to the shipyard and at
that point once the ship has arrived at
the shipyard it's made its drop-off so
in theory the naive navigate is going to
actually be don't move at all because if
we're still trying to get to that
shipyard and we're at the shipyard
it'll be don't move so I'm gonna use
some truly expert logic that asks if
move equals what is it is it can't
remember if its direction with a capital
D yeah both our capital Direction die
still so if the move is don't move
basically that means we made it and it's
time to drop off so we're gonna say
so if move is equal to hold still then
we're just going to say ship States
shipped out ID is now equal to
collecting and the single quotes when
everything else is double quotes is
gonna bother me so we're gonna fix that
okay so at this point they should begin
moving around pretty well so the first
thing I'm gonna do now is test it and
let's see how we've done hopefully no
air is this time I apologize for all the
errors I've been causing okay so let's
go into here and pull up our replays I
cleared all the other ones so I just
have the one right now so this is after
our updates okay so we move out we
deploy
it looks like we actually for the first
time somewhat reliably are collecting
halite and returning it so that's pretty
good so what should we think about doing
next so at least when I look at this
I see a lot of behaviors like where the
a is collect and go back and forth and
back and forth so I think this would be
a little more apparent it's it's
happening so fast because we're not
collecting very much halite so for now
I'm just gonna say let's just ain't
change this ever so slightly nine five
so oops - 0.95 okay so now if it's like
almost to the max so at this point let
me save that will rerun this we'll come
over into our replay here and watch this
replay
this one's like not really too too bad
okay this guy definitely just did it let
me go back again and this isn't RIT like
that action there where it's like zigzag
dig dig dig that's not really beneficial
so what I would suggest is you know
having some sort of maybe slightly extra
weighting associated with just maybe
holding still we can see it at least
initially right at the start of the game
it doesn't appear to really be an issue
that happens too much but as there's
less highlight remaining in the general
area it does appear that the ships do a
lot is exactly that we'd really rather
than just finish the job pick up all the
halide all right so that would be the
next thing I would probably start doing
and there's probably a few ways that we
could do that one option we have those
just whenever we so highlight dict
position equals highlight amount one
thing that we could throw in here is
just anywhere in here you know we could
do it here even if let's say if
Direction equals Direction dot still we
could say this is this times four or
let's do three four seems a little
egregious else it equals the regular
halide amount so in this case hopefully
we should stay a little more still so
let's see how we do there let's run it
whoops I'm not that might have been my
fault okay no it wasn't my fault
okay what do we got here
is oh my gosh I've been throwing in a
one here dude okay all right that's
awesome
really cool I mean I'm really having a
good time with that one okay okay back
to where I was let me see here I think
that's the hardest thing about halite is
the way that you're executing everything
is like so blind that and then the way
that halide is working with all the
other languages because everything is
just like using standard output stuff
and that just makes it really tough when
it comes like it makes it great because
we can use any programming language but
it makes it super challenging when it
comes to debugging but anyway let me see
okay we're definitely moving back so
let's do go back to time 0.995 and then
oh the other thing was multiplying if it
was uh let's see how they ticked if
halide dict equals how light amount else
logging down info attempting to move
position choices okay and then here was
the other thing so if Direction equals
Direction dot still we want to do that
[Music]
times four or let guess we'll go with
three and then else okay let's try again
shall we no errors let's go whoo only
warnings up to 83 though that's kind of
scary let's see how we did
replays throw it in can we go find I
can't remember if we know okay okay so
they collect return collect return and
they're a little less moving around I
can't remember what we maxed out with
before and in fact I think we have too
many replays but it was it's gonna be
any of the replays that has like a
significant so it's probably this one
here so at the end here we ended with a
little over 20,000 talat or so whereas
prior to this we were picking up halite
but we weren't getting anywhere near
that's the same amount so holding still
definitely helps and then the other
thing that we could do is see like for
example like once you get to this point
the question could be at what point like
when really should you turn around so
right here we're turning around at point
nine five what if we tried three three
save that come back here
rerun the game come over here grab the
replay that's a much shorter replay that
doesn't look as good at all
I think cuz they're probably getting
stuffed up there that would be my guess
I don't know they don't look nearly
there like it doesn't really look like
they're getting jammed up too much a
couple of those ships definitely got
jammed up I'm tempted to run it again
one more time I definitely think that
guy aired out did we make it - no we
didn't make it far enough I'm not sure
why that bought aired out that's
interesting who was that that would be
player this player probably or maybe we
need to go down one more player one go
to the end max is an empty sequence okay
so probably what happened there is like
like for one of these ships like if
they're not well it would be one that
would be a ship that was not in port I
guess or I guess it could be a ship
that's in there basically that ship
can't go anywhere because he's
surrounded by our own ships one thing
you'd probably wanna add later on I'm
not
gonna work on that in this video but
ships can swap positions they just can't
go to the same position so you could
swap positions with any of the ships
though and that would be better
so anyway I'm gonna go back to 0.95
because apparently that was the way to
go let's see if this one gets as many as
that uh initially did that's interesting
we didn't really get like any warnings
at all let's come back over here throw
in the replay how did we do pretty good
again so it looks like after turn about
200 I think cuz that's in our code we
only made ships up to turn 200 we might
want to go a little higher than that so
you might want to change that and how I
need more than that that's fine and the
shipyard not occupied that's fine too so
let's try going to make ships all the
way up to turn 300 okay the game ended
let's check this replay we also should
try like a bigger map okay so that was
not nearly as good let's try a larger
map though so this is a 32 by 32 I think
we can have all the way up to like a 64
I'm not sure if they we ever do like a 2
players 64 by 64 game though it's a
pretty big game game is ended let's just
check what we got here also does not
look as good so I guess we'll just we'll
stick with the turn number 200 then
that's fine let's run that again and
then after this we can just submit the
by so submitting the bots is kind of the
same as it was before only now you can
really just copy and paste it into the
little interpreter thing and that should
be fine and then you can run it
otherwise you just need to submit as my
bot on this one didn't go as well either
I only got to about 10k 200
but whatever so if you want to submit
the bot it's really as simple as just go
into play basically copy your code go to
the editor paste in your code run it
make sure it works probably a good idea
I'm pretty sure on this one we can make
it run at least ten eggs I wish they
would add 10x to the other replays that
would be nice there we go okay oops go
back here
cool yeah this navigation is just not
very good that would probably be the
next major thing you'd want to work on
is just fixing the navigation like again
this guy just ran out of possible
options but regardless when you're ready
you can just hit submit and that uploads
your bot otherwise what you just need to
do is have your little folder with HLT
in it and then your main script so it
should be like my bot dot pi is what it
should be called zip that up to
something you call like submission zip
and then you can go to play and they
just drag and drop it in here so again
and just in here you can see - my bot
dot extension and upload it so anyway
that's all for now
if you got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise probably I'm gonna start
transitioning into doing machine
learning BOTS rather than rule-based a I
bots so that's what I'm gonna be
focusing on but if you got questions
comments whatever on the bots up to this
point feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you guys in another
video